every Esports star has a different claim
to fame some players are known for their
fiery tempers well astralis can actually
continue to put the pressure on Vitality
here
some have iconic nicknames to match
their equally iconic play Styles 34
houses
and some are forever immortalized
through that one career defining
performance all of mice that I I love
you God help me and I won't measure but
unless their Moonlighting as a WWE
wrestler or top 8 at a certain fighting
game tournament how many Esports Pros
can say they're known for their walkouts
valorant Pro Benedict Ben kaitan might
just be the only one that guy though
this guy is just happy way for this
time he's always been
coming out with a funny workouts oh whoa
Bangkok let's go baby
oh God this is hilarious I I love paper
wrecks so why the hell does Ben Kai do
this what does the rest of the valorant
community think about it and do benkai's
flashy entrances have anything to do
with his team's success on the server
just to spray it on going wrong and then
he finds shots
he's a god
[Music]
okay so before we start talking about
Ben Kai I must plug our merch yes we
have merch t-shirts hoodies in tons of
different colorways and sizes head over
to shop.thescore.com check out the
Esports collection they're honestly
really sick I have a lot of them I wear
them all the time you should too okay so
here's what you need to know about Ben
Kai he's an appreciator of fine cuisine
what would be some of your key takeaways
from the tournament so key takeaways uh
cheesecake at a hotel is amazing the
steak also is pretty good they never
know what the soup of the day is he is a
role model for his teammates
as a meme guy because he always is
trying to be funny he's like a father to
me and the man always spits the truth
Sean Garris is so handsome I said hi to
him like during one of the half times
yeah but as you might have already
gathered benkai is primarily known for
being a gigantic troll I would say that
I want people to me as a meme with Bren
unable to attend your team is the sole
representatives from Southeast Asia how
does that affect your mentality and
pressure you might be feeling coming
into the event uh
no I'm just kidding I can speak English
okay so are we gonna see a serious paper
x does that exist
nope
that's it just know yeah fair enough
where's tomcon he was supposed to be up
here you were playing a second ago
what's that that was Tom
[Music]
so where did Ben Kai and his Mimi Squad
come from well as is the case with many
valorant players paper wrecks got their
start in CS go and back then benkai had
a very different idea as to what makes a
successful igl I still haven't reached
my goal of actually reading something so
that's why I want to achieve with this
team and like I think like I think I
have the assets to do so now so that's
why I want to take this one seriously
unfortunately in 2020 the world of pro
CS go shrunk significantly for any
roster that wasn't already a tier one
Contender so paper X's competitive
Journey ended before it ever really
began I could tell that they were really
pretty sick of playing Cs and just
wanted like a change the team was
offered a choice between taking a pay
cut or switching over to valorant and
obviously they picked the latter the
team spent 2020 and most of 2021
competing in Regional qualifiers in
Southeast Asia T events but their region
couldn't contain a sheer force of nature
like PRX by September of 2021 they were
headed to their first International
valorant event stage 3 Masters Berlin
and this was where the world was first
treated to Ben Kai's walkouts I honestly
had no plan on like what movements to do
at the end I just had a plan to like
show off that I was I'm actually wearing
two jerseys I don't think even my
teammates knew for the whole time like I
had it on since the morning it was like
a surprise to them too so I just thought
that was funny yo show that's gotta be
oh there's one of the best entrances
right oh that was like is he about the
evening I was like what are we gonna do
right now
what the hell is called what what is
this what is he brushing his teeth
uh
unfortunately supermassive Blaze
eliminated PRX before we got to see too
much more absolute Madness paper x came
out on map one and showed me I mean
justifying why they're here why they're
able to put up such a fight against
Vision strike as you can see what it
means on the face to them Absolute
heartbreak but we did find out that
benkai's priorities did a bit of a 180
since prx's CS States I didn't really
want to be like one of those boring
teams that just come out looking all
serious you know I just wanted to like
lighten up their atmosphere and I mean
if you can't be remembered as like the
best team you might as well be
remembered as the funniest right PR RX
kept on grinding when they got home and
eventually qualified for Masters 1 as
the number one APAC seat going straight
into playoffs in Iceland an
accomplishment Ben Kai acknowledged in
the most Ben Kai fashion imaginable now
does it mean Team bro like we just go in
and just like uh you just do whatever
you think is fun to us and we just feel
like we just want to have a good time
actually and you know when we when we
practice of course it's serious because
we want to improve and we want to get to
these lands but when we actually get
there I'm not gonna say that we're gonna
treat it as a joke but we're just going
there with like good spirits you know
and whatever happens just happens like
it doesn't really matter like our goal
is already done what happened was that
PRX took a top four finish against some
of the world's best valoran teams with
Ben Kai deploying strats that were just
as unconventional as his entrances like
unironically using yorub for example
that operator now ready to take them
down the shots missed though a Lifeline
perhaps and they've caught him on the
way out the flash is perfect
the decoy was popped and they shot it
they know that they're coming forsaken
with another kill and Mankind tucked in
the corner how does forsaken get away
with that he was so low and a third is
bound as well one away from Viper's pit
Tom I mean that's devastating if you had
it online he can flip this round in his
favor completely
the old out of forsaken confirming
exactly where he is he hears the steps
The Flash is hell
oh but first for
eign
flexes on him at the end you can
understand it after a round like this
but off meta picks and weird walkouts
weren't the only reason that PRX quickly
became fan favorites
they kept it real like having Ben Kai
air out the team's dirty laundry in
interviews level of real we are looking
to fix our dirty laundry
because in the hotel we've had
pretty much dirty clothes up till now
and we and the laundry like the laundry
guy just left on Friday because it's
Easter and we knew that yeah we had to
we had to win this match we wanted to
get clean clothes so that that's all we
are playing for so PRX were kind of on a
roll both with the jokes and the
gameplay going into Masters Copenhagen
Ben Kai and his Squad were ready to
bring the pain be prepared to see the
same amount of damage that we don't
Enriquez and obviously
meme some more so the dinosaur cost you
I'm sure there's a story behind this
there is a story I think he's they lost
their luggage again so it's just
whatever you could get from the costumes
thank God this guy is just I I've been
waiting for this moment for quite some
time he's always been coming out with a
funny walkout that kind of the full
protective gear I want him to play with
that the whole series spray it down
this is hilarious I I love paper wrecks
now as much fun as PRX were having
during their walkouts they were deadly
on the server sending opponent after
opponent into the lower bracket under
Ben Kai's leadership PRX personified W
gaming their aggressive unconventional
style relied on decimating their
opponents as early as possible but it
truly thrived on chaos
look at Ben kite making the wrap around
silently on the road only two more
bullets in the Headhunter to swing no
tracks he puts in enough damage that's
some good work but ultimately it looked
like it's gonna be coming up with too
much without the pistol why not faster
than a Reload oh no oh no oh
these guys I've got so much Whimsy about
him I love this team I see you doubting
the frenzy well do you remember our
players on light Shields a frenzy on
Bankai for final round to have look it's
not ideal but Jing's gone he's sending
it again the reveal's huge Dick's got
two and now the Rolling Thunder and off
of that Dingo that's a green light
what they're looking for they're also
looking for Bankai and Bankai is able to
get another 4v3 here in favor of paper
Rex and it's gone from bad to worse but
can yay snatch it back no it's gonna
have to be finesse Vandal in hand but
it's a knife that's out and Ben Kai gets
three another track play Yay he's caught
out man he didn't have a chance and now
from forsaken he's only able to get one
but the Malia from crashes keeps him
back for now the movement
4v2 and paper paper
and this strategy took them all the way
to the Grand finals you cannot predict
Jing and look they're not even allowing
to play
in the play applying so much pressure
before sekatsu's even
a fraction I get this I'm just playing
with it
damage was done prior and the main guy
paperwork they're ripping them to shreds
so left in hands a shower only had a
guardian the aggression that you see
from Forsaken and Jing the sage running
towards melt and on the other side your
anchored Ben kite divide what a monster
making a serious case for MVP in this
tournament and in this map finally gets
taken out by forsaken who goes for a
slide play one after the other please
just keep happening and sure the time
pressure dodged but fex spent half the
round just trying to get a race online
it's all down to Angel and he can't
handle it paper x are taking us to a
fifth
[Applause]
we're going in Full Moon yeah let's go
out with a bang gift paper x holding on
ciao
One Step Closer Josh One Step Closer
that's got them through the choke point
as well this is where things start to
get very dangerous incredibly dangerous
but still forsaken performing under the
pressure to get to Ames the reset
absolutely ridiculous
merciless in their run throughout the
lower bracket and have now taken down
the people's Champions the most fun team
we had in the tournament no fun allowed
sadly after a very close series the boys
went home with silver I did lose in a
pretty um heartbreaking way I do feel
like a sense of accomplishment because
I'm definitely just proud of my team and
we never once like a lost side of the
mentality that we should have brought
which is just to have fun even though
they didn't win this was the team's
highest placement yet at an
International Event a huge
accomplishment both for PRX and APAC
losing in the fashion that we did
obviously kind of hurts
but not for it's not gonna hurt for a
long time because you really know that
we've made history today just being an
Apec team and being in the grand finals
that is like legitimate history I think
it's only like the first of many for us
and then came the big one valorent
Champions 2022 in Istanbul and of course
Ben Kai had some fresh new walkouts for
everyone to enjoy
oh my God
I mean it fits what the
is going on oh man another time
that we get venkai bringing out some
food and no one wants to take it on the
server things looked promising at first
but pretty soon PRX were fighting for
their lives this is actually happening
it's my freaking divided I cannot
believe what we have just seen as Dubai
is now in a one V five thirty seconds to
try and hold on to this and it looks
looks like the fire to the destined for
greatness 13 to 11. I was looking at
some of the stats and I was like their
retake potential no wonder they let
paper explain that many times they want
almost 50 of the retakes whereas paper
wrecks only won one retake of that
entire map and our Jing's position
spotted given away
a 5v1 to keep your tournament life
aligned to keep the year alive and
nothing is found your final SCA
Representatives your final eight pack
Representatives obviously after their
Triumph in Copenhagen getting booted in
groups was tough but just because they
lost didn't mean that Ben Kai dialed
down the hijinks
which is just
um
not expecting to win
and anyone who thought that clowning was
Ben Kai's only Talent had another thing
coming you need someone outside of the
team to see what's going on and just to
really calm everybody down and sometimes
the iGo just isn't able to do that
especially if he's not having a good
game I really like Spanky on the desk
the game over that's cool that's cool he
did analyst right after yeah
so what exactly is the takeaway here
well it's that having a good time and
being good at your job aren't mutually
exclusive that being able to laugh at
your own mistakes can be a recipe for
Success that developing your own unique
approach can make all the difference
that in a game like valorent where most
teams try really hard to look as cool as
humanly possible it's refreshing to see
someone like Ben Kai who's not afraid to
be silly or to challenge the status quo
in-game or out all while leaving every
other cool competitor
in the dust oh look at that guys
watching him he started shooting his
body and he looked up to see his
reaction
this guy
but I like I want The Brood War Esports
poses but like the ones were like back
in 2010 when Jay Wong would walk out and
just go like
[Music]
or like the like
like the ones that are so cringe that 10
years later they're like actually like
gangster people look too cool now